[Music]  birthday trip to hawaii come on birthday  girl  we actually have another surprise for  you johnson willing to take us the  island how else are you gonna finish  your books it was supposed to be a  surprise  surprise  [Music]  do not miss that trip home  [Music]  the first people to set foot on that  island since its forced  shutdown what happened here again dozens  of unexplained disappearances  and the locals swear by the existence of  the half-faced girl  so much for hawaii's scariest resort no  ghosts  all stories they're not just gonna be on  display sam  we should probably go home we have a  little bit of time the weather is  getting really weird  this doesn't feel right are you sure  this is where we came here  [Music]  someone's here who is that  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  hey  [Music]  three  [Music]  you